bienvenidos de nuevo estamos en esta
ocasión en el problema número 7 de la
sección número 8 del examen número 3 que
por cierto que bueno que no hice este
problema en el vídeo pasado porque luego
cuando hacemos problemas de manera muy
rápida no se entiende nada y creo que no
aprendes mucho así que vamos a hacer
este mismo problema con más calma y
ahora sí con un poco más de tiempo
bueno pues empezamos con el problema
número 7 que por cierto nos dice lo
siguiente a 2 elevado a la x 2 elevado a
la b por 2 elevado en la cem esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 64 para a b y c
enteros positivos enteros enteros
positivos
vivos y además me dicen que a sea
distinto de que sea distinto de c
enteros positivos distintos y realmente
yo lo que quiero saber es cuánto vale 2
a la más 2 a la ven más 2 elevado a la c
esto es lo que yo quiero saber a así que
creo que una buena forma para empezar a
resolver este problema es fijarnos en la
parte de aquí arriba vamos a escribir
esta ecuación 2 elevado a la x 2 elevado
a la b por 2 elevado a la cem a cuánto
es igual esto bueno recordando un poco
las leyes los exponentes si yo tengo ha
elevado a la vez por ha elevado al hacer
pues esto es lo mismo que ha elevado a
la vez más los exponentes pasan
sumándose así que de esta misma manera 2
elevado a la x 2 elevado a la vez por 2
elevado hacer pues esto es exactamente
lo mismo que 2 elevado a la a
ver más en esto recordando las leyes de
los exponentes y bueno esto por otra
parte nos dice esta ecuación que es
igual a 64 esto es lo mismo que 64 muy
bien ahora habrá forma de escribir 64
como 2 elevado al álbum es decir verlo
en base 2 pues vamos a ver por acá 64 yo
lo quiero escribir en base 2 así que voy
a factorizar al 64 64 tiene mitad la
mitad de 64 es 32 32 a su vez también
tiene mitad la mitad de 32 es 16 16
tiene mitad que es 88 tienen mitad que
es 44 tiene mitad que es 2 y todos
tienen mitad que es 1
por lo tanto estoy diciendo que 64 lo
podemos ver como dos por dos por dos por
dos bordados por dos o dicho de otra
manera 2 elevado a la 1 2 3 4 562
elevadoras 6 64 es exactamente lo mismo
que 2 elevado a la 6 o dicho de otra
manera 2 elevado a la a más
+ 2 elevado a la amas base esto tiene
que ser igual a 2 elevado a las 6 y si
esto es cierto no queda de otra
aquí estoy diciendo que hay más ven más
se tiene que ser igual a 6 pero además
recuerda que a veces tienen que ser
enteros positivos y tienen que ser
distintos así que a ver pensemos un poco
3 enteros positivos que sean distintos y
sumen 6 aun creo que eso está muy fácil
si nosotros pensamos por ejemplo que
avale 1 b vale 2 y se vale 3
entonces me quedarían 12 más 3 lo cuales
6 perfecto dicho de otra manera los
números enteros positivos distintos que
suman 6 es 1 2 y 3
es igual a 1 b es igual a 2 c es igual a
3 muy bien pero ten cuidado no hemos
acabado el problema ya tenemos casi la
solución de este problema ya encontramos
esto pero recuerda que realmente yo lo
que estoy buscando es esto de aquí todo
esto de piero que yo estoy buscando ok y
como lo encontramos pues vamos a hacerlo
lo que queremos sacar es 2 elevado a la
a
+ 2 elevado a la vez más 2 elevado a la
cem pero ya sabemos cuánto vale a bs
esto es lo mismo que 2 elevado a la 1
más 2 elevado a la 2 más 2 elevado al
cubo y cuánto es esto a pues 2 elevado a
la 1 es dos más dos elevado al cuadrado
2.64 más cuatro más dos elevado al cubo
2.64 por 238 más 8 entonces esto es
igual a 248 lo cual es 10 más 4 14 14 es
la respuesta de este ejercicio número 72
a más 2 b más 12 esto es lo mismo que 14
que por cierto es el insisto y ya está
tenemos aquí la respuesta de este
problema número 7 aquí por cierto es de
decirte que a mí me encantó ha sido de
mis problemas favoritos
pero vamos a resolver el siguiente el
problema número 8
que dice lo siguiente si tengo una
circunferencia
con centro en el punto voy a apuntar lo
aquí el centro de esta circunferencia
está en el punto 3 menos 7 y además
sabemos que un diámetro de esta
circunferencia empieza en el punto menos
2 - 7 am lo voy a apuntar aquí el punto
inicial inicial
de el diámetro de un diámetro diámetro
diámetro es el punto menos dos menos
siete ahora lo que me preguntan
es cuál es el punto final de este
diámetro guau este problema está muy
padre
creo que la forma más divertida de ver
este problema es verlo de una manera
gráfica y con esto crear una buena
intuición así que para esto dibujemos
los dos ejes para ver cómo nos queda
nuestra gráfica aunque date cuenta que
el valor de y es menos 7 en ambos puntos
por lo tanto va a estar mejor que tome
algo más o menos así como mi plano
cartesiano me voy a tomar algo así y
algo así con un dedo catch seno y voy a
poner que este es mi eje de las 10 y
este es mi eje de las x perfecto y bueno
ya que tengo mis dos ejes vamos a ver
dónde está el centro el centro está en
el valor de 3 123 está por aquí pero
además tiene coordenada en 10 menos 7
así que vamos a bajar en menos 7 12
4 5 6 7 entonces estamos parados en este
punto justo aquí está mi centro mi
centro que tiene como coordenada 3 - 7
ok y por otra parte me dicen que uno de
mis diámetros pasa por el punto menos 27
este es su punto inicial así que también
vamos a graficar lo el punto menos 27
aquí va 123 para acá va a ser menos uno
menos dos y también menos siete así que
estamos justo aquí aquí tenemos el punto
inicial le voy a poner para esto una y
el punto inicial menos dos menos siete
muy bien y tengo una circunferencia cuyo
diámetro empieza en este punto y llegará
hasta un punto de por acá es más vamos a
dibujar esta circunferencia tomémonos un
color de circunferencias a este me gusta
y vamos a hacer nuestra circunferencia
nuestras circunferencias se ven más o
menos algo así se debe de ver algo así
perfecto y por lo tanto el diámetro del
que tanto nos estamos refiriendo se
vería algo así pasaría por este punto
por este punto y tocaría como por acá
este sería mi diámetro muy bien ahora
date cuenta que este diámetro tiene como
punto inicial a este punto como centro
pasa por el centro y además debe tener
por aquí a otro punto a un punto final
que también toque la circunferencia y es
justo lo que yo estoy buscando este
punto final pero para obtener este punto
final date cuenta que tenemos la misma
altura en james tenemos la misma altura
en jet que es menos 7 menos 7 este punto
inicial el centro está en menos 7 y por
lo tanto este punto final debe de verse
de la forma algo coma menos 7 algo como
al menos 7 lo que hay que saber es
cuánto vale el valor en x porque sabemos
que el valor en llevarle menos 7 debe de
tener la misma altura ahora lo padre de
las circunferencias es que son
simétricas bajo cualquiera de sus
diámetros es decir que si yo dibujo aquí
uno de sus diámetros
la circunferencia debe de ser simétrica
o dicho de otra manera lo que pase de
este lado también debe de pasar de este
lado por lo tanto si este punto está
justo aquí debe de existir otro
equivalente justo acá y para esto date
cuenta que el centro va a ser su punto
medio es decir que la distancia que hay
de aquí hasta acá esta distancia debe de
ser exactamente la misma que la
distancia que hay de aquí hasta que la
distancia debe de ser la misma
equidistante de este punto el centro de
su punto medio y bueno esto tiene toda
la lógica del mundo lo único que me hace
falta saber es la distancia en x y para
obtener la distancia en x pues primero
vamos a ver qué distancia de aquí acá en
x la distancia que hay de aquí acá en x
es de menos 2 a 3 lo cual es 1 2 3 4 5
es decir que de aquí hasta acá hay 5
unidades y por lo tanto la distancia que
hay de este punto a este punto en x son
5 unidades una vez que ya sabemos la
distancia que hay de este punto a este
punto entonces va a ser la misma
de aquí a acá por lo tanto también aquí
debe haber cinco unidades pero como no
cambiamos en el eje de las diez entonces
vamos a cambiar en el eje de las equis
vamos a irnos cinco unidades después de
este punto para obtener el punto final
de este diámetro y bueno cuánto es cinco
unidades después del punto 37 en equis
bueno pues habrá que sumarle a 35
unidades es decir me voy a mover para
cada cinco unidades y esto va a ser
igual al punto 8 menos 78 con al menos
73 más 5 es 8 123 45 unidades y voy a
llegar al punto final que es el punto 8
menos 7 por lo tanto ya está el punto
final final es el punto 8 coma menos
siete que es justo lo que me pedían y
por cierto es el inciso iv así que ya
está ya tenemos la respuesta de este
problema y pues bueno vamos a hacer el
problema número nueve este problema me
gustó mucho y fue fascinante resolverlo
y bueno pues es hora de que resolvamos
el problema número
qué me dicen las reglas para subirte a
un cierto juego en un parque de
diversiones piden que un niño esté en
una estatura mayor a 75 centímetros y
menor a un metro 25 centímetros am eso
es muy importante vamos a escribirlo la
estatura de este niño tiene que ser más
grande que 75 centímetros más grande que
75 centímetros vamos a ponerle aquí la
estatura y esto tiene que ser menor a 1
metro con 25 centímetros y esto es lo
mismo que 125 centímetros para no
confundirnos entre unidades de metros y
centímetros y bueno lo que me dicen es
cuál de las siguientes desigualdades
representan esta misma expresión
solamente que con valor absoluto así que
no nos complicamos la vida y mejor vamos
a ver esto en una recta numérica voy a
hacer una recta numérica por acá esta va
a ser una recta de américa y fíjate bien
voy a suponer que éste
es muy punto 75 centímetros 75
centímetros y por acá tengo un metro con
25 centímetros 125 centímetros muy bien
por lo tanto la estatura de este niño
puede estar en cualquier valor entre
este y este valor todos estos son los
casos factibles para la estatura de este
niño todos estos son los casos factibles
para la estatura estatura ahora bien si
lo queremos ver en valor absoluto
porque no pensamos primero en el punto
medio entre estos dos valores es muy
importante que cuando quieras escribir
algo en valor absoluto hablemos de
distancias y de las distancias al punto
medio qué valor toma el punto medio
entre 125 centímetros y 75 centímetros
pues a ver sumemos los 125 75 es 200
entre 12 100 bueno claro esto era muy
obvio el punto medio entre estos dos son
100 centímetros 100 centímetros o dicho
otra manera la distancia que hay de
y hasta acá son 25 centímetros 25
centímetros y por otro lado la distancia
que hay de aquí hasta acá también son 25
centímetros 25 centímetros muy bien el
valor de 100 centímetros voy a ponerlo
con otro color para que lo veas de una
manera distinta 100 centímetros
bueno pues voy a decir que cualquier
altura o estatura factible para este
niño tiene que estar a 25 centímetros de
100 centímetros la diferencia que debe
de haber de la estatura del niño menos
100 centímetros esto en valor absoluto
tiene que ser menor a la distancia que
hay de la estatura de este niño a
comparación del punto medio es decir 25
centímetros esto tiene que ser menor a
25 centímetros la estatura del niño
menos 100 centímetros que es el punto
medio tiene que ser menor a 25
centímetros es decir que el niño va a
poder entrar al juego si la distancia
que hay de su estatura a 100 centímetros
es menor que 25 centímetros
como es valor absoluto esto es
exactamente lo mismo que pensar que 100
menos la estatura de este niño tiene que
ser menor que 25 centímetros centímetros
esta es una de las propiedades más
sencillas del valor absoluto y que por
cierto esto es lo mismo que el insisto
de aquí está la respuesta a este
problema
este problema tiene como respuesta el
inciso de un problema que tiene que ver
con estaturas y con valor absoluto
100 - la estatura es menor a 25
centímetros y ya está vamos al último
problema de este vídeo quiero resolver
el problema número 10 así que vamos a
hacerlo con mucho cuidado el problema
número 10 ok y hablando de poco tiempo
estoy viendo mi reloj y me queda menos
de un minuto para acabar este vídeo así
que mejor vamos a dejar el problema
número 10 que por cierto tiene que ver
con volúmenes de cilindros
para el siguiente vídeo nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo hasta la próxima